♪
TREY: GOOD EVENING THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US, I AM TREY
GOWDY.
MARK TWAIN SAID THE REPORT
WAS MY DEATH WAS AN
EXAGGERATION, SO TOO IN
POLITICS IN 2008 BARACK
OBAMA SWEPT TO OFFICE WITH
MAJORITIES IN HOUSE AND
SENATE.
IT WAS THE END OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY SAY SAID,
TWO YEARS LATER PRESIDENT
BIDEN LOST THE HOUSE AND 4
YEARS LATER THE HOUSE AND
SENATE.
AND 2016 PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP WON THE PRESIDENCY AND
HAD MAJORITIES IN HOUSE AND
SENATE.
4 YEARS LATER, REPUBLICANS
WERE OUT AND DEMOCRATS
CONTROLS EVERYTHING.
THE GOOD THING ABOUT
DEMOCRACY THERE IS ALWAYS
ANOTHER ELECTION ON THE
HORIZON.
IF PAST IS PROLONG, ELECTION
NIGHT 2022 WILL BE A LONG
NIGHT, DEMOCRATS FACE
SEVERAL HEADWINDS, THE
PANDEMIC IS STILL HERE, THE
ECONOMY IS SPUTTERING, AND
CRIME, AND HISTORY WHAT IS
LIKELY TO HAPPEN IN
MIDTERMS, THE QUESTION IS
WHY DOES IT ALWAYS SEEM
TO HAPPEN?
DO POLITICAL PARTIES OVER
READ ELECTION RESULTS,
DEMOCRATS CONTROL THE SENATE
RIGHT NOW, BUT THEY CONTROL
THE TIE BREAKER, IF NOT FOR
JOE MANCHIN AND KYRSTEN
SINEMA.
DEMOCRATS WOULD CONTROL
SENATE AT ALL.
HOW MUCH OF A MANDATE CAN
YOU HAVE IF YOUR POWER COMES
FROM A SENATOR IN WEST
VIRGINIA, A STATE WHERE
BIDEN DID NOT WIN A SINGLE
SOLITARY COUNTY.
PERHAPS AMERICAN PEOPLE LIKE
CHECKS AND BALANCES, PERHAPS
WE LIKE CHANGE OR PERHAPS
THIS IS HOW PEOPLE RESPOND
WHEN POLITICALFORGET
ABOUT THEM, THEY CREATE
POLITICAL CHAOS.
THE QUESTION IS, WILL THE
CURRENTLY IN POWER FIGURE
OUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT
COMPETENCE, NOT
TRANSFORMATION, THEY WANT A
BETTER AMERICA.
NOT A DIFFERENT AMERICA.
AMERICANS HAVE MORE IN
COMMON WITH JOE MANCHIN AND
KYRSTEN SINEMA THAN THE
SQUAD, EVEN IF THE MEDIA
DOES NOT.
WILL REPUBLICANS PUT THEIR
DIFFERENCES AND AMBITIONS
ASID